this past weekend let's connect that
boom boom oh right oh yeah
thank you guys happy Monday
happy Monday August 28 the year 2017 a
lot of years huh
a lot of years in the books this one is
coming in hot coming in hot boy it's
coming in West it's coming in wet we're
celebrating dark days right now it's
what we're trying to do I just want to
send some some love and some light and
some thoughts and prayers out to
everybody that's affected by Hurricane
Harvey you know and they make it sound
so nice Harvey you know what's Harvey
gonna do you know
Oh Harvey don't ever do nothing you know
they make it sound like a like a you
know a fella in the neighborhood that
you know still lives with his parents Oh
Harvey you know collecting bottle caps
and doing that you know Harvey open up
his own window washing business and they
went out of business you know friggin
Harvey stealing all the Christmas
candies but then that's not what it is
you know and it shows up and it's more
violent a lot of times in its name and
and my thoughts and feelings and
everything go out to those people in
Texas that are struggling if you have
family members down there in Houston you
can make a donation you can text Harvey
har ve y to nine zero nine nine and then
I make a $10 donation you can also I
believe to the Red Cross you can also
look online JJ Watt who is a Ameena just
a a volatile beautiful you know
capable caveman from the NFL from the
National Football League has started a
fundraising program you can look it up
online you can donate there as well but
I'm happy to be here with you guys today
you know that rain that rain comes in
and it's heavy that rain comes in and
it's heavy if you're dry today and
you're able to drive down your street or
get out of your home you know for you
that's probably you know you're probably
doing better than a lot of people you
know a lot of people down there
struggling and I'm gonna find some other
ways that I can donate but thank you
guys for being here with me today I
remember when I was young I was a heavy
sleeper I was a heavy sleeper man I mean
I would dream that I was sleeping
and that's when you're dreaming that you
are asleep you know that's that's heavy
that's double sleep you know you know
you're under two realms of a brain piece
and so that's where I was at and I
remember one time fell asleep and a lot
of rains came because I grew up in
Louisiana and a lot of rains would come
and and one time the baseboards or
whatever the thing was rotting at our
place and and the water came in while I
was resting and I remember it getting
all on the floor an inch or two and I've
been resting in my mother's room and she
had a package of I guess you know how to
say this is probably but feminine care
sticks you know those feminine care
sticks that women use and and that some
men might even use I don't even know
what's going on these days but you know
these feminine care sticks and that
we're still in the packages and they had
gotten you know a box of them had gotten
caught in the water or whatever they
were floating all around the room and
they had a bunch of a sack of
marshmallows because I'd sometimes I'd
have me a little bit of marshmallows you
know before I go to bed or or just I'd
keep up sack by mouth by my bed
sometimes and they had a sack of
marshmallows that had you know the water
had opened up and there was just all
these feminine care sticks and
marshmallows kind of floating around the
room and they had they had the
neighbor's cat was over and was kind of
kicking these feminine care sticks
around the water and it was it was wild
because I was so scared but here this
cat was finding so much joy you know
snacking on these marshmallows and
kicking around these feminine care
products around the around this little
lake that had formed in our home so you
know what I'm just saying is sometimes
you just even though it's tough you know
find those bright moments you know even
when the rains when the water gets deep
I had a friend I texted a friend in
Houston to check on him see how he was
doing and he sent me back a picture of
this Cajun Navy and that's people that
have these airboats that are able to get
out in their neighborhoods and help
people out and you see a lot of it I
mean it's just us
I mean it's that's a neighborhood
Dunkirk right there
that's neighborhood Dunkirk flaring up
you know when you got a fellow just
showing up at your doorstep you know
bringing you pizza you know cold water
or the phone charging whatever I mean
that's it's beautiful to see how people
helping each other out but he sent me a
video of in his own neighborhood you
know of a boat going by is pretty just
interesting to see you know something
you normally wouldn't see in a
neighborhood you know you don't see a
lot of boats on streets so that was
interesting man and I appreciate him
sending that in but my thoughts and
prayers and well wishes go out to all
those people struggling down there in
Texas and I'm looking forward to making
more donations as those opportunities
arise but Harvey you know they named it
Harvey and that's what I don't like
about some of these storms you know cuz
it fuses a senior citizen you sitting
there and you hear oh Harvey's coming
you know what's Harvey he's harmless
you know Harvey sounds like that boy in
the neighborhood that never really got
it together you know that maybe that boy
that had a you know he had a flick of at
ism' in his brain or something light you
know he's still live with his parents
and he was always you know doing small
businesses pressure washing or you know
paint and people in the neighborhood
would hire him to paint stuff that
didn't need to be painted just so Harvey
could get him a little bit of pocket
money
you know or Harvey would always be you
know that you know Harvey never got it
together you know he's still living in
his parents basement in his 30s you know
and he you don't invite him at the
Christmas party because he steals all
the Christmas candy and they give it a
name like that Harvey that sounds like
it could be a miscreant or a
door-to-door salesman but then it shows
up and it's violent and sometimes I wish
they would start giving these these
storms names that showed who they were
you know you know here comes Manson you
know here comes Ray Lewis you know what
about that here comes Ron Artest is
coming out you know see who we got you
know this Timothy McVeigh this storm you
know give them something that Elise is
gonna put if you're a senior and you
hear Harvey's coming might not be as
aware you might not hide the cat on top
of the cover but if you hear that um you
know that Lee Harvey Oswald
is showing up you know you might be make
some different different adjustments in
your home so it's just alarming you know
and it's sad and I'm not trying to make
light of the scenario that people are
dealing with but I've been through some
water times and they're really tough but
it's amazing to see if you can if you
can find them and you can find the joy
to see you know what people are doing to
help each other out and when we're far
away instead of pointing fingers and
thinking about this or that what we can
do is to donate you know the money helps
money helps at all thank you guys for
joining me on this Monday August 28th
2017 you know it's crazy to see winter
is coming you know winter is coming and
Mother Nature you know she lifting her
dress up and she got a cold crotch and
we're about to see some of that wrath
show up you know when people talk about
these you know the climate change and
the warming and this and that and who
knows you know how much that's affecting
us at this point exactly in certain
areas you know I was in Canada in
Vancouver this weekend and there was
some drunk girls who were all fired up
about global warming saying we want
beaches you know we sick of the winners
we want beaches out here and it's like a
look you can't have beaches just so
everybody else can suffer in the world
but outside of that I was in Canada this
weekend I had a good time I went up to
Vancouver we had a fantasy football
draft a destination draft so every year
my fantasy football league one of them
we do a destination draft we pick a city
and we all fly in and we meet up and we
do our draft we've done some you know
we've done Austin we've done Chicago New
York where else New Orleans
Los Angeles San Diego some other places
Miami and we hit up Vancouver and
Vancouver's a kind of City it's it's a
small city I mean you can almost walk
everywhere and you kind of feel like
you're just waiting for the city to get
going that's what I kind of felt like
you know it's a small city very
friendliest people I mean friendly men
and women if he's talking to men or
women it just there's a nice vibe and
there you don't feel like anybody's
putting on airs they're trying to be too
cool for school you don't feel as much
pomp and circumstances you do here
specifically in Los Angeles I you know
where you go to a bar to a night event
and everybody's trying to be that fancy
cat you nobody trying to get you to you
know smell their breath to let you know
that they had the best tune of that
night you know they trying to get you to
take a hit off that albacore off their
tongue but you don't feel that up in
Vancouver it just felt like a good vibe
friendly people kindness everywhere you
know you stop and ask somebody for
directions they take you there I mean it
you know we asked for directions to this
Beach and somebody just took us there I
mean it was a couple of miles it was 15
minutes you know but it was captivating
a little city you're just kind of
waiting for the city to get going you
keep feeling like oh there should be
more of a an energy or a bustle but
people are they're just more at peace
you know and I've always thought Canada
was a very peaceful place but I was you
know like and New York's kind of got in
that way New York it's gotten so I don't
want to say gentrified cuz I don't
gentrified just means white but whatever
the financial version of gentrified
would be it's gotten so greenify
modified they in New York you don't even
get mugged anymore you know you got to
go up to you know north of Harlem they
even get mugged you know in New York
it's like you walk around these days and
it's just everybody's it's just a bunch
of businesspeople people with money you
know you almost want some you almost
have to ask somebody to you know [ __ ]
you up a little you know stab me a
little or something just you know call
me a pervert and you know hit me in the
back of the knees with a broomstick
could just if you want to get that vibe
that you know that New York II you know
mug me you know I want to feel something
I want to feel like I'm in the city and
you can't get that in New York proper
anymore in Vancouver you're always
you're just kind of waiting for it to
pick up but it's just a peaceful city
there's just peace going on we had a
nice time though well we had a great
fantasy draft there we went out to this
place called Kitts Beach they have a
beach and it's it's it's like right on
the edge of the city and there's people
out there just enjoying themselves it
almost looks like you're in heaven
I mean it's extremely multicultural and
you're out there and everybody's just
enjoying themselves
everybody seems to be having a good time
it definitely seems like they like kind
of the heaven you would picture in your
brain you know there's like there's
mountains in the background and there's
there's City there's skyscrapers and you
know even the homeless people seem to be
on the uptick you know like they were
like they can still at least remember
the homes they had you know they can at
least still remember maybe a 2-bedroom
2-bath that they used to spend time in
you see the homeless people in America
they're you know it's just like they
just been you know boil and soup in
their own eye sockets you know half of
them don't you know like they've been
gargling their own bile you know the
homeless people here there's tattered
they've been through the wringer they've
been through the you know they've been
caught up in the dark arts for too long
they don't even remember how to use a
faucet you know a lot of you take them
by a sink and they just you know they'll
urinate or just jerk off into it but you
don't see that up in Canada you see
people even the homeless people they're
ready for homes again you know they know
they're not going to be homeless forever
you know hell half of them probably just
camping I mean these people love the
outdoors in it's summertime but if you
get a chance to go to Vancouver you want
a nice getaway for you and your lady the
nightlife was pretty chill it was chill
nightlife which for me these days is
good you know I'm not out there trying
to find the erroneous you know female
tits and doing cocaine out of people's
buttocks and all that you know I'm
trying to be more relaxed and and so we
had a nice time but a good fantasy
draft' out I got a good team
one of my buddies lost his mind and I
hadn't seen this in a while one of my
buddies the the three guys went and they
got themself a chocolate bar from one of
these marijuana outlets you know in the
marijuana these days when I was young
that marijuana it was just that brown
that dirt you know I mean hell this
chick half of it had was pine you know
that was one of the flavors it was pine
you know I mean this [ __ ] somebody could
have just cut it in their front yard
earlier that day the stuff you were
buying when I was a kid and you'd smoke
it in the dark he had no clue what it
was and half the time you didn't get
[ __ ] up you just acted [ __ ] up and
that was the that was that marijuana
back then but now these kids you know
these young buckaroos they're hitting on
this
this this stuff you know it's like it's
like Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
this stuff will take you to Narnia
you know this stuff I'll have you fall
out of the back a room out of your own
brain closet into the end of the next
realm and they had a guy in our league
who had never or who said he had smoked
weed a long time ago I think he was
still trying to live a little and catch
that vibe and he ate a little bit of
chocolate dude he started geek he
started getting lifted you know you
could you could almost hear his brain
stem just detaching from his spine this
dude was just a human balloon just
floating around the room yet I start
marching he started marching took his
shirt off do [ __ ] up people like to
take their shirts off huh cuz I got to
get out that cage boy let me out this
cotton cage I'm [ __ ] up this polyester
this polyester cane told me this dude
was lifted and gifted you know he was
feeling that vibe dude he could feel the
vultures just start to play a tug of war
with his um with his cerebellum and he
was getting lifted dude and he's not
like that kind of guy you know he even
texted even sent the group text we're
all sitting there in the room he sends
the group text a text saying I'm having
severe adverse reactions from marijuana
at this moment and he said he did that
just so he would have documentation of
it like this dude's like a research kind
of guy you know he likes that
documentation but man he had his shirt
off he had us call him the the place
where he bought the chocolate bar he
only had one Square and he got bent he
got bent out boy he got bent out he was
catching uh he was catching he was
catching levels you know he was on that
third or fourth level due he was hitting
warp zones he was fighting Bowser in his
brain he started marching around the
room in a circle the room made a full
circle we could go into the bedroom and
then come out through the bathroom back
into the living room in this hotel room
and he he he hit that circle I mean he
was out there like Hussain Bolton on
them vault on that voltage boy on that
plant ography you know in that garden
that was just growing up through his
soul that weed and the [ __ ] was powerful
to watch dude we had to pray with him he
we had to do a prayer
this dude we bought on a bunch of orange
juice we had him in the shower he was
marching in the shower so anyway we got
to dinner late we got to dinner late
that night well we did our fantasy draft
we had a good time in Vancouver I would
recommend Vancouver it's not the night
it's not as crazy nightlife if you would
think but some great hiking extremely
wonderful people I met a lot of fans as
being out and about had some great
seafood and just a fun safe place if you
wanna get out to a vibe I mean I feel
like I could have slept on the concrete
out front and I would have woke up and
somebody would have um probably put a
couple of blankets over me and maybe
even put them ear ear drums in my ears
to make sure that something didn't wake
me up it was that kind of environment
where people just seemed like they were
helping each other out but we watched
the fight man I don't know if you
watched the fight or not man it was good
huh it was interesting I mean right out
of the gate I was thinking did you see
the referee the referee that looked like
first of all it looked like he was just
talking to Connor but I guess maybe the
rules need to be redressed to him
because it's you know boxing straight
boxing isn't his deal but the referee
looked like every Greyhound bus driver
I've ever had
well if you saw that gentleman are not
that beautiful and he had that booty
like a debt that des booty you know he
had that down-syndrome booty and a lot
of um you know some of you guys know one
of my better friends growing up Derry
had D s and Down syndrome popular
disease and he had it and he he was uh
you know we seduced eat sandwiches and
stuff and do a little bit of you know
like ghost hunting and stuff like that
by the ramada when I was growing up but
but man this referee looked like every
Greyhound bus driver so out of the gate
I was like I'm into this thing you know
this this fight feels already familiar
it was exciting man it was exciting the
ring girls looking lovely and at first I
felt so nervous I don't know anybody
else felt that but for the first lie I
mean the first two rounds I was so
nervous and I I can't even feel why you
know what I think back like why am i why
I feel this way I think I was just
nervous
because you know McGregor was seemed so
out of his element you know even his
stance and everything it was just he
looked so vulnerable to me you know and
I don't know what ton of mailboxes you
know no it's not about fighting I know
that both these guys are masters in
their universes but it made me nervous
man I was nervous for him you know the
first two rounds and then after a while
I just felt like you could see the flaws
were just they were natural flaws in
Connors he didn't have any finishing
moves you know he didn't have that that
high you and he didn't have that power
he didn't have that power play he did
you know he had just a lot of these
straight punches and you know I was just
like where's that finishing move at one
point I'm just like just you know throw
a kick daddy you know throw a knee burst
but he didn't have a finishing move and
that kind of feel like made it a little
bit tough and I wish that I know he at
the end of the fight and he said you
know I wish they were to let us go to
the mat where one of us fell one of us
hit the dirt and I think at the time he
probably thought that but this morning I
bet that he was probably glad that it
didn't happen that way
you know that it didn't go down like
that that it ended how it did I mean
it's really interesting to see I hope I
you know I want him to fight somebody
else next Andy Dick
you know who else could he fight a rod
I'd love to see him take on a rod
I'd love to probably see him I'd love to
see him honestly beat Chris Paul's ass
you know if he'd go in against if he
going against Chris Paul I'd love to see
you know or Martina Navratilova you know
some of these people that want to be
young Gunners and get in there but we'll
see man it was it was exciting I I
wonder if maybe in in the original
agreement if he would have asked for an
MMA referee that was something I was
thinking like would he have rather like
an MMA referee who maybe you know might
have at least been able to judge and
referee the fight a little bit more you
know not to his liking but in a
comfortable manner I think it would have
made it a little bit more fair I mean it
was it was heavily favored to Floyd
whenever you whenever you look whenever
you were looking at it like even when I
when that when I first came was like wow
okay this is this is boxing you know
this is an MMA at all I mean this is
boxing and you really saw somebody step
outside of their comfort zone I mean
it's really inspiring
you know you saw they had a lot of
videos and stuff of these guys doing the
after party and really having a good
time and but yeah I mean I was look I
was it I was nervous it was exciting to
watch you know but it was inspiring like
man me I want to work out hard you know
I want to do something I want to step
outside of my comfort zone you know I
want to be a baker you know I'm saying I
want to challenge you know i want to
challenge my [ __ ] on some donut
level you know i mean we want to step
outside of my comfort zone you know i
want to wake up and you know in in four
months i want to go you know toe-to-toe
with the archaeologists you know [ __ ]
where are these bones I'm out here you
digging I'm digging you could shovel I
could shovel it made me want to kind of
change up and feel inspired and then
this morning I just you know pretty much
a little bit of that left me because you
know inspiration man that stuff you have
to be reminded man I wish you could have
inspiration like an IV a drip bag of
inspiration that's what I need a lot of
times because I will feel inspired and
then it will go away it will go away but
good to be here with you guys I hope you
guys had a happy weekend I was in
Vancouver I flew back this morning had a
couple of sets tonight at the Comedy
Store and at the Hollywood improv and
I'm so happy to be here on this past
weekend I have an announcement to make
to a couple of them one we got a new set
we got a new set it's coming along you
can go to YouTube whenever the podcast
comes out on YouTube which is Monday
evening or Tuesday morning and you can
check it out you can let me know what
you think also this week we're going to
launch our patreon account that's patr
Aon slash Theo von th EO vo n and it's
just to support the podcast directly you
know if it had as some advertisers come
on in people have reached out and said
look man I just would love to support
the podcast directly and personally I
want to continue improving this show you
know I love doing this show I'm so
grateful for this experience I want you
guys to know that well you know I was
nervous when I started out you know and
I'm still nervous you know I'm nervous a
little bit every time I get on here and
start you know sharing and I don't know
what I'm doing sometimes if I'm sharing
too much or not sharing enough but I do
feel like
you know like together that we're doing
something good we're onto something good
and I want to take it to the top you
know and I want to include some options
online where people can you know become
more involved and that where we can work
more together and so that's what the
patreon will be and we hope to have that
launched on Wednesday so you guys can
check that out if you so choose no
pressure no matter what you will always
have this past weekend on your Monday
mornings all right I want to let you
guys know some dates
we have September 6th through 9th that's
next weekend I'll be at cap city in
Austin if you have friends or family in
Austin tell them to come on out
September 14th through 17th I'll be at
hilarities in Cleveland and the November
17th through 19th I'll be at stand-up
live in Huntsville Alabama I'm excited
about all those things feeling pretty
excited man you know I felt a little bit
nervous tonight before I started
sometimes I guess I get a little nervous
you know I get a little bit nervous of
what the you know what the vibe is and
what you guys want to hear what what I
want to talk about and I just appreciate
you guys being supportive and sticking
with me we've got a lot of great calls
that came in and I want to just get
right into him and some of them are
really really interesting so let's crack
in to the hotline calls right now the
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three if you're down in
Texas and you had an experience from the
rain you know where you saw something go
on that you thought was pretty
remarkable and I'd love to hear a little
bit about that you know that's one of
the things you can hit the hotline with
as well if you're just going through
something and you want to share it you
can hit the hotline with that anything
that if I've been through it as well I'm
happy to share you know I don't have
advice but I do have suggestions and I
do have my own experiences so that we
don't have to feel alone all right let's
check in with this first call right here
hey what's up Theo Tim from Tennessee
all right Tim from Tennessee I can hear
that I can hear that jingling you're in
your jungle man and your neck and your
neck instrument you know that VBox baby
I can you spouting off that sweet
southern you know you got that molasses
in you
and you sound canal let's hear more I'm
calling about a an issue I have so I
have this cousin who's trying to be a
rapper a Christian rapper actually you
he's got a cousin trying to be a
Christian rapper man that's why baby you
know you know it's whatever I don't
really like Christian rap dog pretty
much terrible but if that's what you
know people get all of that and it helps
them you know go for it but the problem
is that he's he's terrible you know Wow
the problem is is that he's terrible man
he dropping hymns and spinning rims baby
you know what I'm saying he's caught up
in that CR something that Christian rap
having babies with virgin ladies Partin
sees and y'all turning up out there in
that Bible Belt he's dropping it off huh
and you think he's terrible well look I
feel you man I have friends that have
thought that I think are terrible at
stuff that do things you know and and
I'm gonna stop you right there but I'm
guessing that you're just wondering how
to handle it and here's what I say what
do you lose by him giving it a shot you
know he's gonna go as far as he's gonna
go with it you know he could be great
there were times for years when I was
not good at comedy and if somebody would
have really said that to me I might not
have kept going and I'm not saying that
I'm great today but I'm saying today
that I can do my job and I've been on
and I can I can say that I'll do my job
well but you know you just can't take
away his hope so I think if you can
offer you know if you have constructive
suggestions firearm Adam because dude I
mean this guy's getting into a crazy
game I mean I know there are some
Christian rappers that are that are
popular I think most of them are black
so it probably good to see some you know
some diversity in the market could be
good I'd love it if actually you could
hit the hotline in and drop one of his
tracks and maybe we could even start one
of the podcasts off with it next week so
if you have the ability to do that or we
can email it to me at theof on th EO vo
in at
Mack and Macey dot-com but I appreciate
you calling and saying this you know and
you got to think that Jesus balled out
you know I mean he was a rapper in a way
if you want to think it whether you
think about him is up the Savior you
think about him just as a human being I
mean I do was you know spittin in the
desert
Jesus was dropping lyrics in the desert
you it's hard to even keep moisture in
your mouth in the desert so at the very
least boy he was a hmmm if you feel me
it's hard to even keep your tongue wet
in the desert and he was roaming around
dropping tracks dude you know so I mean
there's some respect there you know I
mean that's real stuff so I just support
his ability to try something different
try not to be too hard on him buying
some gold teeth you know maybe maybe
make it something that you enjoy you
know buying some gold teeth like you
know five gold teeth and spell out you
know hym in s and put them him put that
hims in his grin you know or get them a
gold necklace with three nails on it you
know it's hard sometimes with family you
know to support him because for some
reason family when they do some [ __ ] it
will drive you way more crazy when
friends do you know I mean my first my
sister you said she did one of those
things on Facebook one time were it's
like I'm gonna say some I'm thankful for
for the next 700 days and man I wanted
to speak up I wanted to say I feel like
that's crazy but it doesn't matter what
I feel you know so I'd find a way to
embrace it you know maybe get a tattoo
on your back of him [ __ ] dropping
mattracks you know the lamb boy the Lamb
of Jeezy boy you know he's spitting
straight fire wool you know so see what
you can do there man is support and just
don't take away his hope I think you can
offer him some suggestions if you feel
like it or ask him if you want
suggestions but don't fire him off and
take away his hope maybe see if he could
be a background singer that [ __ ] would
be hilarious because then you're
embracing it you're part of it
so I'd find a way to embrace it if my
brother came to me and said he wanted to
be a Christian rapper
dude I would gain about 150 pounds and
put on a core address that them thick
them thick girls them girls that got
them um you know them uh you know they
got them them bassists you know they got
that deep throat you know where they can
gargle them they can gargle different
sounds down there you know and I would
put on a big robe and I would support my
brother thought he'd be hitting them
background Jesus desert dang dang dang
dang dang three days three days later
I'm back back back back
Easter Easter play that back up baby you
can help him out good luck with it
thanks for calling
onward next caller it was Josh I'm not
here in Charlotte North Carolina and
Charlotte North Carolina us North
Carolina for those you guys who don't
know Josh thank you for calling like
this he come down to the comedies on
here and saw they'll be cool to see you
man I've been there before to Charlotte
and the only time I was there I was
there for at the comedy zone I had a
good time I'll be back next year I don't
know the dates but I saw Cam Newton I
was there for 40 minutes I've been in
town I'm sitting on the on the outdoor
patio of a McCormick and Schmidt's
having me a little salad and Cam Newton
went by with a baby carriage pushing his
son he had a newborn already been you
know a few months old and he's pushing
the son and a baby carriage and at first
I thought it was a homeless guy because
he was you know you don't see a lot of
adult men at all just pushing a baby
carriage by themselves down the street
and he also don't see a lot of adult
black men at least I'm not used to
seeing that pushing a baby carriage down
the street and he had on this you know
kind of a Gucci hat and a scarf
and I'm like dang this this do might be
homeless but then he got closer and I
was like holy [ __ ] this dude is Cam
Newton so you never know man you never
know when a homeless person might be Cam
Newton you never know you might be
surprised onward oh so you get some
advice from if you could help me with
started dating this girl and she's a bit
of a squirter oh okay see you hitting
him you hitting them waterworks baby you
passin uh you pass then I don't know if
it's Baltic Avenue or Marvin gardens and
you hitting them waterworks with the
ladies
okay you know this is kind of an edgy
topic but we're gonna try to field it
here thank you for calling homeward I
always thought that that was cool at
first you know especially when I feel
like it was important obviously or
something but yeah them sprayers you
know them Gunners you know remind you
going to the fair when you play that
game you trying to shoot that thing and
get that animal from that old man and I
do usually probably look like you have
some kind of a skin cancer or a lung
cancer but onward I know what you're
talking about man after a while I said
getting hotter Newman I have to change
the sheets all the time and going to the
store get detergent and these people are
probably like students got a lot of
clothes or something you know yeah with
detergent and also by inter detergent a
lot of people think he might be cooking
it down and doing some kind of a new
dope and that's one of the issues out
run cuz I you know I've at times in the
past I had me a little bit of an afront
habit you know I get that Afrin and I
use the suggested dose now I'm not
riding outside of my suggested dose
circles but man sometimes coming around
11 o'clock dude you know my hands start
feigning for a hit off that Afrin for a
hit to you know get my nasal passages
sedated but yeah I can feel you man so
you deal with a lot of extra lawns you a
lot of extra laundry because you got Old
Faithful in the bedroom onward but I was
giving some advice on that man it's just
like it's just for mass man and I really
like the girl too but uh I mean how do
you know it's interesting man because I
met a girl years ago who had she'd moved
to town she dated one of the Jonas
Brothers I don't know which one there's
three of them I think they all damn
looked the same beautiful young man from
what I remember I never looked at him
very closely but this gal uh you know
she was she was really extraordinary
a little and yet first you like oh this
is a party you know daddy's here you
know I'll do without Walsh dishes down
between this gals legs you know but then
after a while it's that ain't no joke
you know that's a it's a liability you
know unless they're you know putting
extra use to some of that activity like
they're watering plants or you know
refill on the fishbowl it can be a bit
overwhelming at times you know so I
don't know what you do because I don't
wanna make her feel bad because this is
a natural thing and look we all have
things naturally about us that our love
when our spouse doesn't alike you know
it could be that you clear your throat
or you pick your nose while you drive or
that you have a lot of body gas and
sometimes if I don't sleep well I'll get
a little extra body gas so you know I
know that I can be you know I have
things about myself but maybe find some
other ways you guys can be sensual
without hitting that gasm you know
without a you know hurricane harvey
stopping by y'all's bedroom every night
because that can be wild you know so
maybe talk to her about it see how she
feels
because yeah otherwise you got to keep a
stack of towels there in the bedroom and
you got a really sound off otherwise
other than that I'd say make it fun you
know put a couple of barrels they used
to have this thing a little buckets they
used to have this show called the bozo
show or something where if you got a
thing in you threw these balls if you
got it in a bucket you got you a Subway
sandwich and then have children on there
and this one has just been locally but
they have this guy Bozo the Clown or
somebody the grand prize game you throw
these ping pong balls at these buckets
if you got it out to the five bucket
then you got you maybe a Subway sandwich
for your whole classroom of children so
maybe do that maybe make something fun
or cute about it you know we'll just
make two nights a week we all do sex and
that's the activity night you know in
this you know show up prepared put
floaties on you know be a baller you
know what I'm saying do get that Michael
Phelps neck piece do something you know
but I think instead of you know if you
want to keep her and you do care about
her then you're gonna have to find a way
to make it comfortable for you and then
not talk
to her about it in a way that makes it
uncomfortable for her man that's a tough
one that is a tough one man and if
somebody somebody out there has a good
advice for this gentleman you know about
his uh about his damp damsel if we will
then hit the hotline and let him know
and I'll try to do a follow-up episode
this week were where other people can
give you some return advice about that
damp damsel and how to handle that but
yeah that it's interesting is the things
you see in pornography man you get those
things in real life dude that's not it's
not the same thing you know if like you
got a girl out there they had this one
thing you know years ago some girl was
eating uh she could eat doughnut holes
with uh with her hoo-ha and yeah that's
great you know that's cool on a you know
on a brunch maybe a Sunday brunch you
know you partying with your new
girlfriend you know and you haven't you
a little bit of fruit or some you know
yogurt and she's doing she hiding
doughnuts you know she calorie it up but
do come you know a couple months of that
you having a run of the store all the
time and get doughnuts and [ __ ] that
shit's crazy and what if her hoo-ha
starts to upscale and that thing wants a
Butterfinger or a payday you know or a
hundred grand or a thousand grand that
thing starts hiding whatchamacallit and
almond joys in its cheeks dude then
you're talking I mean then you're
talking the dark arts so the things you
see in pornography sometimes they can
escalate when you get him in real life
but I would approach it in a way if you
do talk about it with her in a way
that's comfortable for her you know if
you just want to make her feel bad
because once she starts feeling bad
about our body that's gonna be
uncomfortable for everybody man you know
but good luck man I appreciate you
calling in about it brother who you
partying out there do wherever you are
North cackle at any partying all right
next caller onward for somebody this is
Nathanson Kansas City
this is Nathan from Kansas City I just
picked your defense and my fantasy
football league I hope they do well
autumn or Nathan I'm inside a quick
question for you man I agree referred to
a few real good friends of mine and it's
kind of slowly drifting apart and I
believe that
they're actually pretty upset with me
now I'm not sure what it is that they're
said about but I would like to sit down
there the man I'm kind of talking out
and okay you grew up with two good
friends and they're really upset at you
but you're not sure what they're upset
about and you'd like to sit down
man-to-man and talk it out that's what
we got so far homeward thanks they don't
so they don't respond to text messages
so I'm kind of at a loss of what to do
maybe you should help me out with some
advice on the subject here and a little
bit Sheryl all right thanks for calling
man love the show man I appreciate you
you enjoying it I love you brother
you know I want you to feel good about
this do but it sounds like you know
they're upset they're calling you you
know they're upset but you don't know
about what you know and I don't want to
I don't want to sound and believe you
man but you got to have some inkling you
know if you know they're upset you know
but you're not sure about what you
probably got to have some inkling you
know and if they don't want to respond
to you right now then you know obviously
if it's two of them you know they must
be really upset about it so I mean I
think there's two things here one I
would just give them some space you know
maybe they're moving along maybe you
guys don't even need each other maybe
you know maybe this friendship has run
its course or two it sounds like there's
a little more to the story I would own
up to whatever happened and go see him
face to face
and own up 100% and I wouldn't own up
with a but you know look man you know
this happened but I felt this way I'd
leave the butt off of it I would show up
own up to whatever you did personally
and don't ask for like you know if you
want continued friendship and say look
bah you know I want to still be friends
I wanna still be buddies you don't want
to still split KitKat's together you
know I want to still you know sit around
and hot dip in our mouths together and
do friendship you know I want to still
sit in a in a room and have your body
heat be in the distance
if you still want those things then let
them know that but you're also gonna
have to probably if there was something
you did you're gonna have to you can
have to apologize to it I'll do it
man-to-man I wouldn't hit the phone
lines I would do it man-to-man and I
wouldn't say any buts I would just
apologize and let them know look I'd
still like to be friends you know adult
friendship dude this shit's tricky out
here because adults they get busy
sometimes their wives don't want them
hanging out with other adults you know
people start getting jealousy happens
you know you get a new house but your
buddy you don't have a house yet and
he's still out there in an apartment
jealousy happens you know your buddy
loses his leg and you still got two legs
and next thing you know he don't want to
talk to you because you because you
think you showing off by having two legs
that's crazy you know but adulthood
friendship is hard that's one thing I
was fascinating about about young
friendship to be friends when you were
young all it was was proximity usually
it's like your best friends
still to this day even we're just
usually people that lived near you that
was it you know it's not like there was
this big friend search where you
interviewed thousands of other children
when you were a child it was just who's
nearby oh they are boom boom friendship
it's correct you know it's like a lot of
is just proximity based so you know if
you value their friendship then I would
make it a man-to-man apology I wouldn't
try it on the phone I appreciate you for
I appreciate you calling up let's hit
another call here we're cruising through
some calls man and I appreciate you guys
calling and hitting the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I'm feeling good I'm trying to get
through this it's 12:45 a.m. here on the
Pacific Coast time I got a cool week
coming up we have david alan grier
coming in on our podcast for allegedly
Spencer Pratt as well that episode will
be airing this week I believe on
allegedly that's my Hollywood podcast
you can check it out with my wonderful
co-host Matthew Cole Weiss and we have
who else is coming in it's rumoured it's
room
bird that Chris Hansen supposed to be
coming on so that could be really really
exciting all right let's take another
call here we go
alright let's take another call here we
go
APO this is Cody calling from Boulder
Colorado again this is Cody from Boulder
Colorado you up there in the country up
there were they everybody's eating drugs
and stuff up there in the mountains
thank you for calling first off thank
you for taking my last call about
texting a phone culture I really enjoyed
your poo in the meat taco bell's story
yes a true story and everybody uses the
that there was feces in the meat in
their Taco Bell in their town but this
really happened in my hometown when I
was growing up it really really happened
and it was alarming but we made it
through it as a community and it's
amazing sometimes what community can
overcome together let's hear more and
when you said I don't know if we can go
back relate to texting I really kind of
made me think about some [ __ ] recent
calling this time is about love you like
you don't really talk about that other
than like guys trying to blow you that's
really the only thing we've heard
specifically I want to talk about
monogamy and polygamy from where a man
in Boulder I know in like San Francisco
polygamy is real big okay so from
Boulder he's saying that I don't he
wants to talk about love he's asking me
you know I don't talk about love that
much except for if fellas is trying to
blow me or run my poll
you know if they try to run my poll with
the inside of their face and that it's
probably in reference to when Andy Dick
tried to blow me a few times over there
in Shreveport Louisiana but onward I'll
hear the rest of this um where a man
older no one like San Francisco polygamy
is real big personally I'm sure that I
can marry the same person for 40-plus
years for whatever oh yes curious your
thoughts on that next against for doing
what you do man you're a frickin legend
peace I appreciate your call man I
appreciate your previous call and I
appreciate this one I really do I
appreciate everybody that takes time to
call in and help because this show goes
it goes because you guys call you know
my brain I'm sure I've always had a you
know kind of a short brain you know I
remember they did a cat scan on me and
the man said you got a short brain I was
like what the [ __ ] does that mean you
know and I got angry with him even
though I was just wearing just that one
piece in the hospital
where the back is open where anybody
could [ __ ] you you know which is really
I think very scary to put on somebody
when they're already alarmed and they're
in a hospital I mean I say put him in a
full damn ski outfit but you know they
want to put you in that thing and scary
even more and the man said you got a
short brain he goes the the the the the
width of your brain from the bottom to
the top is not very tall you got a short
brain but that doesn't surprise me you
know I've always had you know a lot of
medical deficiencies or abnormalities
you know my father told me now when I
was when I was young that I had the
heart of a lesbian you know when the man
told me one of the doctors told me when
I was a child that then I had the
ribcage of large large cat probably I'm
thinking of mounting some sort of a
mountain cat probably something you
would see up in Boulder maybe but anyhow
we're talking monogamy and polygamy or
monogamy and can you do it what's it
like these days you know I think I
wouldn't be surprised if we get more
towards a culture where you know where
marriage isn't as necessary you know and
I hate to say it because I want to see
you know I love the family unit and it's
statistically proven across the board
that children survive and thrive better
when they have two parents in the home
and that's a statistic for every
ethnicity go look it up every ethnicity
you know and so it's but it's like is
that what's popular right now you know
is that what's going on and I you know I
don't know it scares me to to think you
know I mean I've been talking to a gown
I was just talking to her about you know
how that makes me feel very nervous and
I think part of the nervous thing about
being with somebody forever is just the
propensity for you to be able to mess up
you know you know it took to cheat her
to to to lie or to you know to not be a
good husband you know and that's the
scary part I think of monogamy these
days you know is man built to be able to
withstand all this constant barrage with
the parent
agra fee and the you know the instagram
and that titties wandering by you know
me nice I mean you open your eyes if you
even open your eyes outside it's like
everything has two T's on it now you
know when you start to see him and it's
just there's there's just a lot of
breastwork out there that there wasn't I
think years ago our grandfather only
time he saw some other breasts maybe if
he went to the store you know or if he
even held a soft melon back in the day
you know if you probably in the 1930s he
if he even held a soft melon that's the
only time he really thought of any of
somebody outside of his marriage when he
was checking melons you know when he was
considering buying fruit I mean he'd
probably now used to be the old Playboy
I probably pulling up to a fruit stand
and feeling the different you know the
plums and the and the different you know
honey dudes out there and just feeling
their softness I mean god damn you put a
you put a c-cup avocado and each one of
my hands and office I mean knob will my
penis will mount up on top of my nuts
and it will be erect so it's wild to
think that that back in the day that
that's all that's the only stimulation
that they had you know when I was young
you had the pornography magazines but
you also a lot of people I think in our
neighborhood were drawing pictures of
vaginas in the dirt and I don't know if
it was just in our neighborhood even
around town there was a group or maybe
just one person and an artist I guess
you could even call him an artist you
know or somebody that was trying to do
graffiti but didn't have any paint and
they would just be drawing pictures of
vaginas in the dirt and you'd be
wandering around town and just see if a
giant in the dirt and that would always
be a little bit crazy you know to see
that and that would make you feel erect
and stuff and you never knew when you
were gonna see that but nowadays yeah
it's like you know it's it's hard to
just conserve your sexual energy for one
person because there's so many things
trying to take it from you nowadays
polygamy I don't know I mean it sounds
like it'd be great of course you know to
maybe have a change of pace in your life
you know but you got to be a great
multitasker would it be good for the
kids you know I don't know enough about
it what the effect that polygamy has on
children you know when you know when you
get dad two or three nights
a week you know when you got your
different types of wives and I mean I
feel sometimes like I have enough love
inside of me to you know to be able to
maybe live in that environment but is
that practical I don't know you know I
don't know man and I don't talk a lot
about my past endeavors man I mean I've
had a lot of sexual sexuality over the
years you know some good and some bad
you know and I don't really even like
sex that much I'm not real keen on it
you know people banging their bodies
into each other you know it's just
sometimes it just gets old a little bit
and maybe that's a dour look at sex and
maybe I need it you know have to have my
Chi you know reconfigured you know I
need to take my Chi into the cheese shop
you know and and remodel my cheap but
that's just how I feel sometimes you
know that after a certain point also
it's just got to be about more than that
to have that connection but it's it's a
great it you know I don't think there's
a man and you know every man thinks
about it for sure about polygamy you
know I think it's natural they say its
natural to want to mount up and do love
and do sex on others they say it's
natural so it's here it's a fight you're
in if you're staying monogamous and
you're in a one-on-one relationship if
you've been in a long-term relationship
and you've stayed true in it I'd love to
hear some of them what that feels like
what some of those values are what do
you what you know what are the prizes
there that you get emotionally for
yourself what does that feel like man if
you're out there you know we're ladies a
lot of these ladies be running around
these days slinging that canal it's wild
out there it's definitely wild what do
we how are we getting on time here man I
think we're getting a little bit along
I'm actually going to let's take away
let's take one more call here and see
what's happening man I want to say this
we got we got a caller right here
Tufte oh hello Louisiana boy a calling
in here from a trip wart la Shreveport
Louisiana that's Randy dick tried to
break me off with them tongue in jowls
you know oma Biddle's Lord uh just call
me Colin with the problems and I'm
currently having I graduated high school
two years ago congratulations if you
graduated high school in Louisiana
congratulations brother not easy for a
lot of people and I appreciate you
calling tonight man thank you on word
currently 20 years old so have some
problems with a success of pornography
use lack of motivation to go out and get
girls uh had a few girls girlfriends in
high school and and every time I get the
opportunity to go any old girl and
whatever always talked myself out of it
whether it's you know insecurity or lack
of confidence all right I appreciate
this man I mean you know this is an
issue that I've struggle with over the
years you know you're having some issues
with pornography and you were dating in
high school but now you're not dating
that much and you're feeling like you
might have you know a lack of motivation
to do that but it sounds like you are
interested in women so onward cuz I have
in the past you know that girls are not
all girls I'd like to put loser but
let's connect understand [ __ ] right now
with that I was just you know calling to
see what's your thoughts on that and I
can kind of pull myself out of this funk
dude you can put yourself right out of
that funk I'm gonna tell you that how to
unfuck
dude how to on go your funk how to
unlock your funk this is how you got to
stop the masturbation you got to stop
the pornography if you feel like it's a
if it you feel like it's gotten out of
control people that that that are just
watching it and enjoying it and not not
everybody's calling and saying they feel
like it's gotten out of control so if
you feel that way that's probably based
on something real you know that it's
become a bad habit it can probably be a
healthy habit for you again one day
but for now you might want to address it
you know and some people think I'm crazy
well dude heat and jerk I'll what does
it make
this fellow just trying to jerk off but
if he now he's reaching out and he's and
he's not comfortable for him anymore
and then it's not a fun game for him you
know yeah I get it do it it's fun you
know I remember cruising on the
interstate and you know blast and went
out the side of a open van door you know
but and that was a blaster but those
days are over
and now when you're just doing it at
home and it's you're not going out and
meeting people so what you got to do is
you got to cut it off
not your wiener bro but you just have to
stop it you just got it you got to find
some ways to stop it you got to find
habits mom
notice what your habits are whenever you
do it and shut it down at night no
electronics late at night shut it down
you know and as you get away from you
get thirty days away from gonna promise
you you'll just start to feel better in
your body you feel more motivated you'll
feel more confident and I'll even tell
you this man they got si ami si a
meetings and that's uh it's sexual
addiction stuff and that can be anything
man
it doesn't mean you out there pervert
you know it doesn't mean you're out
there peeping tom and or you know being
a weirdo they got him I'm looking to
here right here online they got on well
they have them on Monday Thursday and
Friday in Shreveport Louisiana so you
can check them out nobody's gonna know
that you heard it on the air and went
nobody you know anything like that but
go check it out man you can hear about
it you can hear other people share
what's going on with them it's recovery
bro you can get in there and get and
make yourself feel better dude you know
I'm saying get off that seed gun because
you're just getting handy with the seed
gun baby you why hurt when you come to
your cross but you are Wyatt Earp and
that's okay man you just got to settle
that Wild West down you got to settle
that you got to take a wild out of the
West for a while and I promise you
you'll feel invigorated you'll feel more
confident you got to let that Chi built
up you got to let that Chi build up and
I'm telling you that because I know that
you know I'm telling you that cuz I know
it and you ain't alone baby I've been
out in them skeet streets and I know
some people say that I beat this topic
to death play on words of course but but
look if you're calling about it and I
can share about a man that I'm happy to
do that and I appreciate you guys all
here in the hotline we got one more call
here but good luck man and if you even
want to just hit me on the hotline again
I won't put the call on but you know
just to let me know what's going on or
if you want to talk about it in the
future man I'm happy to discuss it but
yeah it's a battle out there dude it's a
battle out there if you want to be a man
that's not caught up in the dark arts
you know that's not out there you know
hiding in the living room while your
wife laying in the other room and you
they wondering why your sex life is bad
and you out there spraying out laying
down in the tub trying to be quiet
jacked up on some pornhub you know it's
tough guys I'm not saying you you're not
wrong for doing it but it's tough and
we're battling that [ __ ] but we're
better than that
you know they create these things to
weaken us to beat us down you think
George Washington was jerking off at
night dude
hell no I do was sharpening his wooden
teeth and being ready for the next day
and they say he just chopped down one
cherry tree I bet that muhfucka chopped
down all of them because he showed up
you know he battled his tough times
imagine having termites in your teeth
and you still got to wake up and smile
it's tough to be a man these days they
don't want us to be a man but we're not
gonna we're not gonna fall down baby
we're not we're gonna we're gonna tow
the line man good luck to you out there
but you can check out those where those
meetings are at at si ADOT recovery.org
and it doesn't mean you're a creeper or
a weirdo do that trust me
cuz I'm the most amazing people you'll
meet her in some of these meetings do
businessman professionals heroes bra
heroes or let's hit one more call here
on this hotline y'all got me feelin
fired up you know what I'm sayin fired
up I'm about to swim down to Houston and
use my body as a sandbag again you can
donate you can text har ve y 2 9 0 9 9 9
you can't find a way to help help like
that take ten dollars out of your pocket
put it into somebody else's it can help
JJ Watt is a great charity that's online
you can hit them up online just Google
JJ Watt charity and see what they're
doing to help out let's do one more call
this call came in from a
gentlemen hey Theo I just wanted to
thank you for the fresh perspective that
this past weekend and continually
reminds me to stay positive and
celebrate living and just had a little
baby girl born three days ago healthy
and happy and gorgeous as ever I
appreciate you doing the Lord's work on
the back of that skullet mm-hmm
Brenda shelves right you're about to
take the comedy game to a whole new
level love you brother take care love
you too man
congratulations do you got that three
day old baby girl huh look at us man
that's it supportive eat you want to
support feminists that's how we do it
we're bringing daughters into the world
you know we're raising them to be good
women you know to be confident to be
able to become good mothers you know
we're trying to lead by example we might
fail at times but we get back up and I
appreciate that call man you know I
really appreciate that call I appreciate
the thank you cuz yeah it's tough out
here man it's tough out here for me you
know and it's nice when I get to get
these calls because you know I wish a
lot of times that you know I had left
out of here to Los Angeles and moved
home and had myself a family by now you
know and had that you know and I get you
know a little bit you know a little
jealous so I appreciate you sharing that
with me makes me feel like I'm a part of
something but yeah man girls little
girls uh are the cutest dude my family
was never very close and then my sister
had a baby when she first had it I was
like man I was so angry at her I'm like
what are you doing you don't even know
about life or you don't know I was just
so judgmental and then man once I got to
know this kid you know and she's just
the light of my life and now she has two
daughters and you know anything they do
just brings joy to me and they brought
so much joy to me over the years just by
being alive you know little girls are so
sweet man it's so that's I appreciate
you sharing that blessing with us you
know and that's what it's about
you know that's what it's about - we're
out here trying to help each other out
to remind each other what we can be boy
we taken this thing so thank you I
appreciate that call man you know
we're trying we're in this together do
we celebrate and living so hit the
hotline check out YouTube and check out
the new set man I'm so thankful to Ken
Hyland one of my producers who helped
put this set together for me man I am -
this is cool we're doing some cool stuff
we got the patreon you can check that
out that should be up by Wednesday and
that is PA Treo end comm slash Theo von
and you can support the podcast directly
we're just gonna have some small ways
you can support and hopefully some other
neat ways that people can get involved
in become a part of this but by hitting
the hotline you can become involved add
a couple more calls on the call list but
I'm not gonna get to them because it's
1:00 a.m. here and I still got to edit
this thing and put it up but but again
my heart goes out to everybody in Texas
and you know if you have somebody that's
down there even if they're not in
Houston text em there's suddenly you're
thinking about them you know let them
know that uh just for a minute that
we're not thinking about ourselves
that's what we're trying to do so I'm
gonna celebrate living man happy
birthday to your to that three year old
and thank you for the callers and I'll
talk to you guys soon man
that is my coffee
and this is a Spencer Jacob growl GRA
you band
and that link will be in the YouTube as
well
celebrate me
[Music]
and as well if anybody has a topic that
they'd like to have us address on the
podcast call in and say hey this is a
topic suggestion I'd love to know
whatever I mean that hotline is open if
you call him mess up or whatever call
back you know there's no judgment on
that
there's no judgment and thank you for
everybody they called and shared some of
their thoughts and feelings really
appreciate it man I really really do I'm
excited today man I'm excited
[Music]
[Applause]
celebrate dog
celebrate oh yeah
sighs
what was this out right here man
guys be good to yourselves I bet you
deserve it I'm gonna try i'ma try man
I'm gonna try no promises but I'm gonna
try man you got to be good thank you